jean vincent brisset bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france pour
parler donc de cette rencontre par
visioconférence aujourd'hui entre les
présidents russe et chinois alors quel
est l'enjeu principal c'est bien de
renforcer les liens dans un contexte
international tendu
renforcer les liens je ne sais pas s'il
ya vraiment besoin renforcer les liens
par contre il ya un besoin de la part de
poutine aux particuliers de d'affirmer
une certaine d'alliance avec la chine de
manière à contrer ce que c'est un outil
ne considère comme une agression au
sujet de l'ukraine
c'est poutine est un petit peu tout seul
s'il n'a pas l'aide de la chine 1 contre
les états unis et contre l'otan
justement selon le kremlin au coeur des
échanges ces tensions actuelles en
europe à autour de l'ukraine qu'est ce
qu'on sait de la position de pékin sur
ce dossier
je suis pas du tout sûr que pékin ait
une position particulière sur ce dossier
lien une préférence pour pour quelque
chose simplement pékin a comme
adversaire les états unis et donc l'otan
donc pékin il ya au moins les les
ennemis de mes ennemis sont mes amis
donc il ya toutes sortes de raisons pour
que pékin
soutiennent quiconque est bloquée contre
les états unis contre l'otan oui parce
qu'effectivement vladimir poutine face à
l'otan dans le dossier ukrainien xi
jingping face aux états unis dans leur
différend territorial avec taïwan est ce
que les deux pays pourraient avoir une
réponse commune à la fois sur ces deux
dossiers d'ukraine et taïwan
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que je ne
vois pas bien quelle peut être la
position de pékin vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
dans la mesure où je ne vois pas bien
non plus quelle peut être la position de
la russie vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis de
taiwan simplement la russie dans une
mesure relativement limitées mais quand
même a besoin d'une certaine liberté de
navigation autour de autour de taïwan
donc tout ce que tu ce que la chine
pourrait faire pour une prise
souveraineté n'arrange pas la russie
d'autre part il reste des contentieux
territoriaux entre la chine et la russie
ce que les chinois appellent des traités
inégaux qui revendique quand même un
million de kilomètres carrés dans
l'extrême orient soviétique et si la
chine mettait la main sur taïwan la
russie pour prendre très bien que
l'étape d'après pourrait être un d'abord
quelques îles au nord de sakhaline et
ensuite les territoires du côté de
beauté de la vie au stop alors il ya
également ce point commun ce sont les
sanctions économiques qui touchent tant
les deux pays on imagine que les deux
états vont de essayer de renforcer aussi
leurs liens commerciaux
les liens commerciaux entre la russie et
la chine ne sont pas nouveaux il est
logique de les renforcer il est logique
aussi que chaque pays le fassent à son
avantage et
la russie a besoin sans doute une usine
du monde alors que la chine auraient
davantage besoin d'une russie fournit sa
technologie
alors là la russie et moscou ce sont les
deux grandes nations qui n'ont pas été
conviés au forum sur la démocratie de
joe biden va dire poutine et si jean
ping tous les deux qui se sont entretenu
récemment avec joe biden cela n'a rien
donné c'est un dialogue impossible
aujourd'hui entre la chine et les états
unis
ont choisi enfin la nouvelle
administration américaine a choisi de
poursuivre la politique
relativement rude que money 30 à l'égard
de la chine en y ajoutant une volonté de
créer des alliances de retrait des
alliances contre la chine est les etats
unis ben on voit à l'heure actuelle le
terme vecten est en tournée en indonésie
en thaïlande et en malaisie
on retrouve cette bonne vieille théorie
du containment qui consiste à bâtir un
cordon sanitaire autour autour de pays
qu'on considère comme dangereux avec une
seule crainte c'est que l'effondrement
d'un pays ouvre une brèche et casse tout
le système de d'encerclement de ce pays
alors le porte parole du ministère
chinois des affaires étrangères il a
aussi annoncé que cette réunion
ce serait un moyen je le cite d'apporter
plus de stabilité et d'énergie positive
dans le monde par où cela pourrait
passer qu'est ce qu'on peut comprendre
on ne sait pas s'il ya grand chose à
comprendre en dehors des mots là la
chine a besoin d'eux dans une russie
bienveillante à ses frontières d'un
autre côté la chine est en train par
exemple de d'essayer de monter une route
du nord 1 pour le passage de ses
marchandises le long des côtes russes en
espérant le dégel de l'arctique et ça je
suis pas du tout sûr que la russie sur
le long terme tout à fait contente de
gens de possibilités merci à vous jean
vincent brisset nous avoir éclairé ce
matin sur ft franc jeu le pas rappellent
vous êtes directeur de recherche à
l'iris et ses listes de la chine